[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JAMES PAINE: Hi, everybody.
My name is James Paine.
I'm with the System
Dynamics Group here at MIT.
I'll give you a little bit
more background on myself
in a few minutes.
But just to be sure everyone's
where they're supposed to be,
this is System Dynamics--
Systems Thinking and
Modeling for a Complex World.
This is a three-hour
IAP overview session.
Just making sure no one stands
up and walks out at this point.
OK, good, yes.
I'm doing pretty good.
A little overview of
what we're doing today.
So right now,
we're in the middle
of the welcome, which is nice.
We're going to do
a quick overview
of What is Systems Thinking?
And I'm going to try
to emphasize this
throughout the
day, that there is
a subtle difference between
system dynamics, the method
set, and system thinking,
the concept and field.
And they overlap, and they
flow in and out of each other,
but they are subtly different.
Additionally, because this is
only a three-hour overview,
we won't have the time
to dive into a lot
of the specific tools, and
methods, and nitty gritty.
Happy to discuss
that in more detail,
or maybe even I'm thinking
about planning a future session
with that.
So one of the things we
thought about-- what's
the way that we can get people
engrossed in this material
as quickly and
efficiently as possible?
And our thought there is,
we're going to do something
that we like to do quite a bit
which is a management flight
simulator.
So that's going to
take up a good chunk
of the middle of the afternoon.
I hope everyone has been
receiving my emails.
I'm sorry for all of them.
But we need
essentially one laptop
per about three to five
people in the entire group.
So I think we're good with that.
So that will give
us an opportunity
to get hands-on with the system
dynamics-fueled simulator,
and then afterwards, we're going
to sit down and talk about how
the lessons from that simulation
tied into some of our earlier
concepts.
And finally, end
with an overview
of some additional resources for
those of you who are interested
not only in system
dynamics but specifically
System Dynamics here at MIT.
So who am I?
I'll say this, I
was not realizing
that the screen was so
big, because my face is
very large up there.
Yeah.
My name is James Paine.
I'm a second-year PhD student
in the System Dynamics Group.
My path here to MIT was
torturous, to say the least.
I worked for approximately
10 years in various industry
settings as a chemical engineer
at GE-Hitachi nuclear energy,
as an industrial engineer
and Lean Six Sigma specialist
at a company called
Inmar, which does
reverse logistics,
and then, finally,
as a product manager at
HanesBrands on the Maidenform
and Playtex 18 Hour brands.
So all over the place.
One of the reasons,
actually, why I found
the System Dynamics
Group specifically
was when I decided to go back
into academia as a career.
The System Dynamics
Group was one
of the few places when,
during my interviews
with different
folks, when I said
I've worked on everything
from nuclear reactors to bras,
their response was,
OK, that makes sense.
And then, my response
to that was, well,
that doesn't really
make sense to me,
I'm curious about why
that makes sense to you.
And then, we kind of
dove into it from there.
And we'll get more into that
sole idea of systems level
thinking.
My specific research interests
are focused primarily
on this concept of behavioral
operations management.
So some of you in here might
be familiar with operations
management as a concept
behavioral OM that specifically
looks at the decision
making processes that
come about as a
result of human beings
existing within a supply
chain and either trying
to work around or with that.
My constant line and
refrain for all this
is, within behavioral OM,
the presence of people
is not a bug, it's a
feature, and what can you
do to kind of plan not
only around but with that.
So a little bit more about
the System Dynamics Group
specifically at MIT here.
Here are our faculty members.
We have John Sterman, Nelson
Repenning, Hazhir Rahmandad,
and David Keith.
John Sterman is a big presence
in the system dynamics
field at this point.
He is the author of-- and I'll
talk about this later on-- this
lovely textbook right here,
which is a big, old sucker--
Business Dynamics.
This has become the de
facto textbook of the field
at this point.
There's a number of different
resources out there.
I'll talk about, again, this
at the very end of the class,
but given limited time
and limited resources,
my suggestion would to be
grab one of the copies out
of the Dewey Library over
here and read the first two
chapters.
That greatly overlaps
what we're going
to talk about today,
and in my opinion,
covers a lot of the fundamental
concepts of system dynamics
and systems thinking.
So very brief history
of system dynamics.
System dynamics is, at its core,
an MIT, sort of, founded field.
It came about out of the
mind of this man right here,
Jay Forrester, and its
origins are in control theory.
So this is-- I want to say--
I want to preface this by
saying this is my view of system
dynamics, and this is coming
from the standpoint of someone
whose background is all sort
of engineering and operations
management.
I've used system dynamics
as control theory
applied to social systems.
And again, you might have
some slight disagreement
from different
people in the group,
but that's at least my
one-sentence summary of all
that system dynamics is.
So the real, seminal
work of all this
was in 1958 when he published
Industrial Dynamics, which
was sort of the first
formalization of these concepts
that we're going to be
talking about today.
Jay Forrester himself--
if anyone here
has a background in
electrical engineering,
you might recognize his name.
He's the original
inventor of RAM.
So his background is
primarily around computers.
He was involved in
the WHIRLWIND I,
which was MIT's first
multipurpose, digital computer.
So he did a lot of work
in digital computing,
a lot of work in the
electronic space.
Actually, if you go up
to the fourth floor--
room 450-- it's the Jay
Forrester Conference Room.
In there, there are
pictures of him on his ranch
that he grew up on.
There's pictures.
There's chunks of memorabilia
from his history of system
dynamics.
There's also an original piece
of hand-woven RAM shoved up
there.
So if you have any interest
in early computing history,
that's kind of a fun bookshelf
to wander through and touch
and feel.
So, really, how this started
was, he came to Sloan
and had this idea
of what can I do
to take my background
in engineering
and apply it to
business systems.
And this was born
out of his view
that, often, when faced with
a problem in this space,
you could get so far with
treating it as a purely
engineering problem.
And ultimately, you would end
up running into social issues,
you run into
bureaucratic issues,
you run into structural issues
inside the organization that
are ultimately trying to
implement the solution that
have to become part of the
solution in and of itself.
So he asked himself, how
can I broaden and apply
some of this theory that I've
already learned and developed
over the course of
my life to this wider
concept of social systems?
His real test of that
came in two forms.
One was an early project
with General Electric
at an appliance plant,
and they noticed
that they had this three-year
cycle, specifically
with regards to their
employment history.
It was sort of boom and bust.
Have a whole bunch of people
coming on board-- onboarding,
onboarding, onboarding--
and then mass
quits every three years.
And the question was,
where is this coming from,
what's happening?
So he sat down and hand
coded one of the first--
what we consider to be--
system dynamics models within
this field and presented it.
And that led to his work
in Industrial Dynamics--
A Major Breakthrough
for Decision Makers.
Where this got a lot
of attention and spread
beyond our group
here at MIT was when
he was invited to
the Club of Rome
and started applying
some of this work
to larger social systems
in his WORLD2 simulation.
This led to a book later on--
I'm sure you guys have heard--
called The Limits
To Growth, which
is, in and of itself, a
fundamental book within system
dynamics but also a
little bit controversial
in the form of that it was
semi-misconstrued as making
concrete predictions
for the future.
Instead, it was trying
to make some comments
about the overarching
social structures we live in
and the limits of resource
renewal and regeneration.
So that's kind of my quick
background of where we are
and how we are.
What's interesting is,
that what that's led to is,
a group here that has a
wide, wide background.
So these are the current PhD
students in our group, with me
down there in the middle again.
We have two other
members in the room.
We have Jose back
there in the corner.
We have TY sitting over here.
Just going to call him out.
Yeah.
But if you look up
here, the reason I
have this up here partially
so you can hunt us all down
later on if you have questions.
And then, also, for
this little line below,
where we all came from
and how we all got here.
And you'll notice that it's
kind of all over the place.
We have some engineering,
we have some aeronautics,
we have electrical.
We also have biology.
We have geophysics.
We have applied mathematics.
So folks come to system
dynamics through a variety
of different means and
methods, but ultimately, what--
at least my opinion on
this is-- it's from someone
taking a systematic
approach and noticing
that a systematic approach
by its very nature
must exist within a
system and how can we
apply that more widely.
So just to give you an idea of
where this can kind of lead,
I'm going give you two
examples of some research
that I'm currently working on.
I'll get back to this later on.
This one is one that I would
consider to be more traditional
system dynamics, in the sense
that-- notice this lovely,
little diagram, which we'll
talk more about later on--
stock and flow diagram
compartmental model.
This is applying concepts
of systems thinking
that we'll talk about a
little bit more later on,
this idea of nonprofit
organizations and decision
making within that
space, and specifically
how nonprofits within
the performance
landscape in which
they operate are
subject to unique and
different pressures
that for-profits
are not subject to.
And this is-- none of you should
be surprised by that sentence.
That's not a crazy thing,
but by its very nature,
you create this--
and by outcome of this paper--
this performance landscape
that says that not only is it
more difficult to be a
nonprofit in certain settings,
it is structurally
impossible for you
to achieve certain
types of goals.
So that's something
that's in the whole line
with this is like why
is it so difficult to be
a nonprofit manager under
certain circumstances.
That's kind of
where it came from.
Totally different
chain of research
here is this idea of
multi-echelon supply chains
and inventory oscillation.
This is built on a classic
model within this space.
Has anyone here ever
played the Beer Game?
Beer Game?
We got a couple of hands.
So this is ultimately
looking at the Beer Game
and me being
frustrated and saying,
we've been talking about
the Beer Game for 60 years,
like, why are we still
talking about it?
What's going on in this space?
So this is taking, again, the
idea of people being people,
letting their order
behavior be what it is,
and talk about what can we do
for an algorithmic approach
to control mechanisms that
exist within a supply chain
with delays.
So in this case, I'm
not really doing a lot
with what one would consider to
be traditional system dynamics
tools, but I'm spending a
lot of time in TensorFlow,
I'm spending a lot
of time in Python,
I'm spending a lot of
time doing optimization
within these spaces.
And that still is within
this larger concept of system
dynamics and systems thinking.
So let's dive in
a little bit more.
I've been saying system dynamics
and systems thinking a lot.
And you guys are in a
three-hour overview session,
so I'm assuming that
most of you guys
don't necessarily have a
strong background on this.
Actually, that's a good
question to ask right now.
Has anyone here taken any of
the system dynamics classes
here at MIT already?
OK, good.
Because otherwise, this will
be really repetitive for you,
so that's great, OK.
So who here has ever seen a
diagram that looks like this?
Does this look familiar?
You have a problem, you identify
the problem, you gather data,
you evaluate alternatives,
you select a solution,
and you implement it.
Anyone here ever worked
in project management?
Anyone here ever worked in
that sort of environment?
Yeah.
So my background
is Lean Six Sigma--
once upon a time-- and this
is a highly-simplified version
of the idea of like DMAIC.
Though, for those of you who
have a background in Lean Six
Sigma and know DMAIC,
don't jump ahead of me
because I'm going to get to
something important here.
So within this concept
of identifying a problem,
finding a solution,
and implementing it,
ultimately what we're
talking about is
that we have some sort of
goal, we want to fix a problem.
We're going to make
some sort of decision.
By making that
decision, we're going
to change the state
of our system.
Great, we did it.
Congratulations.
I'm assuming-- partially given
away by the title of this
section of the slides--
you can kind of tell that
this is not complete.
Also, just by the nature of how
I've arranged these variables
on this board, I'm kind
of giving away where
I'm going with some of this.
Because at the end
of the day, this
is not true in and of itself.
This is all embedded
in a larger system
that matters in the short term.
So when you change the
state of your system,
your decisions have to change.
Suddenly, when you've changed
how you might implement
or control a specific structural
process within, I don't know,
your supply chain,
the way that you
go about managing that
supply chain on a daily basis
is now different.
Additionally, because
of that change,
maybe now your goals are
a little bit different.
Before, you were
trying to-- again,
I'm going to talk in the
language of supply chain--
you were shooting for
that semi-arbitrary number
of 3.4 defects per million
opportunities-- which
I have a whole other soapbox
about why that number is not
the appropriate
number to choose.
And now you've done it, so now
you want to do something else,
so now your goals have changed.
But now, all of a sudden,
by you doing this,
you suddenly realize that you're
affecting not only your one
process but other
processes, other things
within your system.
And that can lead to this
thing we call side effects.
But however, maybe
by me changing
the state of my system,
suddenly a supplier
has to change how
they're acting for me.
Suddenly, maybe an order
stream has to change.
Somebody outside of
myself and my team
has to change their
decisions based
upon the state of the system.
And additionally, that
state of the system
feeds in right there.
So you can see where I'm
kind of going with this.
And additionally, when
everything is said and done
and you've built this
lovely process up,
with everyone at
their own side effects
and building off
everything else like that--
here's the fun bit-- none of
this happens instantaneously.
There are delay after delay
after delay after delay.
So you, making a choice today
that affects your system
and achieves that goal within
that open loop thinking model,
ultimately can come right
back around and affect
that original input again.
This is the fundamental concept
of systems level thinking.
No decision you make
exists in isolation.
No process that you affect
The only difference is the
boundaries of your system.
In fact, I go so far as to say
there are no such thing as side
effects, there are simply
effects that you have not
thought about yet.
So what is a system?
A system is any set of
interdependent parts
with a common purpose.
Now, that common purpose--
I'll be honest-- is
a bit of a caveat,
because as you can
probably tell from this,
if you take the
systems level concept
and apply it ad
nauseum, suddenly you
have a system of every
atom of the universe,
and that ultimately
is not feasible.
You do eventually have to draw
a boundary around your system.
So for our purpose,
very generally,
we're going to say
that define a purpose,
and then your system
is all those parts
that exist within that purpose.
And-- I put my animations out of
order there apparently-- social
and economic systems
are highly complex.
They are dynamic,
tightly-coupled-- and by that,
what I mean is, when
one thing happens,
you can trace it to another
thing occurring somewhere
else--
governed by feedback.
Ultimately, the
decision you make
affects something that then
affects that same decision
process in the future.
Non-linear, limited information,
and there's ambiguity.
And typically, they're
more complex than
human-made, physical systems.
And so, ultimately, when you
take a lovely, little diagram,
like this of one thing--
kind of water flowing down,
water flowing down, water
flowing down-- the part
that people often forget
is that feedback loop
that goes right back
up to the top again.
So when we talk about systems
thinking and system dynamics,
it's really a framework
to help close the loops.
I talked about, before, this
idea of open loop thinking.
That's our method of taking
that process and saying,
what are the processes that
I make downstream, what
are the choices I
make downstream,
and how do they
come back and affect
that first starting point
at the beginning of the day.
Ultimately, what we try to
do within system dynamics,
we have a general framework for
figuring this sort of process
out as best we can.
A big part of it is
eliciting mental models.
And mental models in that
sense is saying-- walking up
to somebody and saying, I
know you're acting rationally,
I know the choices that you
make are the ones that you think
are best for the information
set that you have right now,
I want to know why.
I want to build a model
of your mental process
that when I run it and I look
at it, it makes complete sense,
and then take that
model and then
pop it in the context
of a larger system
and see how those decisions
start coming back and affecting
the outcome.
And then-- that's
exactly right--
taking that mental model
and expanding it outwards
and saying, OK, now
you've made choices,
how can we bring
feedback into account?
Simulation.
So this is one thing--
for those of you
who might have a small inkling
of the System Dynamics Group
here at MIT, a huge chunk
of what we do is simulation.
Because at the end of the
day, it's a heck of a lot
cheaper, quicker to simulate
a social process, and changes,
and tweaks, or
impacts, or effects
than actually going out
there and doing it directly
on social systems.
It turns out that
takes a long time
and often makes people
grumpy if you do it directly.
So simulation is
really, really helpful.
So simulation helps also
improving mental models
by presenting folks with
people, also as a teaching tool,
showing folks self-contained
models and simulations
of a process that both shows
how their mental model fits
and makes sense and
is perfectly rational,
but then also, in
a larger context,
can affect and have feedback.
So this is the big one.
The simulation's purpose
is not to be right.
I put this up here partially
for my own edification
and my own learning.
I spend way too much time
building these models,
both within the core
system dynamics tools
that we'll talk about
a little bit later
and also within my own side
environments of saying, OK, I
want to get this simulation
to match some reference
mode of data as
closely as possible.
And the question there
is, though, being right
is not the same as being useful.
So you want to make
sure that you're
identifying the
high-leverage policy choices
within your model, the portions
of that multi-loop mode
of thinking we talked about
earlier that actually affect
the outcome that you care
about, not necessarily
have a simulation that directly
matches the physical universe
around us.
These are next-- what I consider
to be some of the three core
points of systems thinking
and systems dynamics,
and this is the big one.
Structure generates behavior.
If you walk into a system
dynamics conference,
if you walk into any
room with enough people
who do system dynamics for
more than five minutes,
eventually someone's
going to say this.
Structure generates behavior.
And I'm going to spend
a little more time
on this in a few minutes.
The whole idea of
structure generates
behavior is that the
actions that people take
are possible, feasible,
and rational because
of the universe in
which they exist,
and it's important
to realize that.
And that actually then goes
into that mental models
matter a lot.
So physical structure-- when
we talk about structure,
it's not just the physical
structure of your system,
it's the structure that
exists within people's heads.
It's the choices that they
make when they take an input
and then do an output.
Again, my background is all
process control and process
engineering.
So one way you can think of this
as little tiny PID controllers
floating around in the universe
taking inputs and outputs.
However, figuring out what
those inputs and outputs are
and how people convert
that information
is difficult and should not
be casually assumed away.
And then, finally, the
fundamental attribution error.
This is something that
I added back in here,
because this idea that
our first instinct is
to blame the people
and not the system--
and this goes back to
this idea of structure
generates behavior.
So like, for example, if you're
on the highway and suddenly
someone cuts you off, what's
your initial reaction?
Screw that guy!
What the heck!
Honk, honk, honk.
Now suddenly, you're
on the highway and--
I don't know-- you're late
to get somewhere-- for me,
I got a call that my kid is
throwing up at preschool,
I got to get there in
the next 10 minutes--
what do I do?
I cut somebody off saying,
sorry, it's OK, and I zoom off.
So in that situation-- that
first situation, when I'm honk,
honk, honk, that guy-- that
guy who just cut me off--
what's wrong with them?
Something is wrong
with that person.
No.
There's an underlying
reason, there's
an underlying rationality
behind what they're doing.
I will argue that there
might be rationality
or that person is just
really bad at driving,
but hopefully, that's not it.
But the idea that the
fundamental attribution error
is that our first instinct is
to blame the people and not
the system.
Back to structure
generates behavior.
It is the structure of
the system that matters
less so than the behavior.
And even within our
own group here at MIT,
we have to remind
ourselves of this idea
of the fundamental
attribution error.
And we try to break away from
it, we're not perfect at it.
This is written on the
whiteboard up in our room.
This is one of the first
things I saw when I walked up
to that group, and
at the time, I just
thought it was a
nice saying and I
didn't realize this
was actually addressing
one of the fundamental
decision-making fallacies
that we have to overcome
as system dynamisists.
So this is the basic assumption.
"We believe that everyone
in this community
is intelligent and capable,
cares about doing their best,
and acts with integrity,
and wants to learn."
So the assumption is
that, every person
you meet, every person
you sit down with
has this operating
in the background
and you have to assume
that they are rational,
caring human beings who are
doing what they think is best.
And the moment that you accept
that, then, suddenly, it's
not the person you
have to change,
it's the system in which they're
operating that needs to get
shifted.
So this some more,
kind of, burning
into this whole structure
generates behavior.
You have patterns of behavior--
so events are the most visible.
Underneath events, you
have patterns of behavior.
Under that, you have structure.
So when you look out into the
universe and you see something,
those are the events.
You see those things
happening over and over again,
those become
patterns of behavior.
And then, the system under
which it's generating it
is the actual structure.
So here's an example.
This is all about oil prices.
"Drunk trader caused a
spike in oil prices."
"Oil prices keep
falling-- this is why."
"OPEC rumors continue to
pull oil prices higher."
OPEC turns for high oil prices.
"Another sign of economic
worry-- tumbling oil prices."
Oil prices after tanker
attack in the Gulf of Oman.
So in this case, each
one of these ones,
you notice they're talking
about oil prices jumping up,
oil prices going down,
oil prices jumping up,
oil prices going down.
These are the
events that you see.
These are the points of data.
The pattern is a little
bit more interesting.
You take each one
of those effects,
you can't just draw a
line out ad infinitum,
you want to look at
something like this.
So in this case, you
can see the oil prices--
and I would see this as sort of
a stereotypical boom and bust
pattern.
It goes up, it goes down
for quite some time.
Goes up, and then goes down.
I would actually
even boil in here
and say that it looks
like the amount of noise
around this up-and-down
pattern is increasing
over time, which
in and of itself
is a little bit interesting.
But ultimately,
it's that structure
in the background that matters.
There's the physical structure,
there's the information
availability, and
then there's also
the actual mental model of the
actors involved in the process.
So we talk about this.
This is a whole thing.
Whenever you talk about mental
models within this space,
one of the things
that's easy to say
is, OK, well, you tell
people about this.
You tell them to
consider feedback,
you tell them to incorporate
this information around them,
that that'll fix
it, that'll fix it.
No.
It is incredibly difficult
to learn and change
in a dynamically-complex
environment,
and these are just some
of the information--
some of the reasons why.
I'm not going to walk
through all of these.
I think everyone in
this room, probably,
is on the same page
with me on this one.
One thing I'll point
out, right there,
is limited information
and time delays.
Gigantic reason.
People can only
make the decisions
given the information they
have available to them
in the structure in which
they're able to operate.
To expect someone
to operate otherwise
is to expect them to be
omniscient in some way, shape,
or form, and ultimately, that
is not feasible within a larger
system.
So system dynamics-- in my
mind, the System Dynamics
Group here at MIT is really
applied systems thinking.
It is not a method.
It's not a model necessarily.
It is taking the concepts of
systems thinking and applying
them in ways where we can
get research outputs that
ultimately improve some sort
of social system for the world.
So now having said all that
about systems thinking,
I'm now going to dive into
some specific, actual tools
that we can go ahead and
use here within this space.
Let me make sure how we're
doing here with time.
We're doing great.
All right.
So systems thinking,
ultimately, and system modeling
is iterative approach.
There is no right answer
at the very beginning,
there is only the
answer that you
think is good enough
to solve or address
the problem you care about.
It's a spiral approach.
Just like everything else
we'll talk about with open loop
thinking, the process of
building a system dynamics
model is an attempt
to close the loop.
And it's not just
compartmental models.
So when people talk about
system dynamics models--
if you hear that phrase-- what
they're likely talking about
is this lovely thing over here.
This is from one of
my papers, and I'm
working on it right now.
We'll talk about this in
more detail in a second.
It's called a stock and flow
diagram or compartmental model.
This is often confounded with
system dynamics, the field.
It's partially because
this is the go-to modeling
choice for many people
in system dynamics,
and this is also the
first modeling choice
back in the '50s, '60s,
and '70s when approaching
these sort of systems.
And then, of course, that
says all models are wrong,
but some models are useful
at the end of the day.
So when you're taking
a spiral approach
to systems modeling,
what you want to do
is you pick something
within this setup.
You think, OK, what's
a reference mode.
So by reference mode, I mean
what is a mode of behavior
that you can observe
and pin down.
This person made this decision
when exposed to these inputs
and had this output.
Great, we have a reference mode.
Can I build a model that
reflects that reference mode?
Awesome.
Now that I've done
that, let's go ahead
and add a new reference mode.
Can I make this
reference mode exist
within my existing diagram?
Nope.
Let's go ahead and
add more structure.
And as you add that more
structure, maybe it comes back
and it feeds back
into itself and you
have to go back and kind of
rework from the very beginning.
This is where this
concept of simulation
becomes really, really
helpful, because when
you interview somebody--
as I've done with some of
the work in the, especially,
non-profit space--
you might get six different
stories describing
three different outcomes across
two different possible modes
of behavior.
And the question
there is, how the heck
do I incorporate this
all into a dynamic model
at the very beginning?
My argument there is, you don't.
Pick one.
Pick one to model it, then when
you're done, pick another one
and model that one
and then see, OK,
how do they overlap, how do
they fit into each other,
how can you make this
one, unified model?
And the big thing
is, as you're going
through this whole process,
doing your sensitivity analysis
and you're testing,
you're going back through
and updating your own
assumptions and mental models
about what you think the
problem was to begin with.
This idea of spiral approach.
So, OK, now we're actually
going to jump into some actual--
I said before that
system dynamics are not
compartmental models.
I'm now going to teach you
guys about compartmental models
because we use them a
lot in system dynamics.
Heh.
So this is fun.
So causal links.
A causal link is a
fundamental tool.
So causal link is simply
saying, if one thing
changes, another thing changes.
This is super simple.
So let's start with this one.
You have production,
you have inventory,
and you have shipments.
If I increase my
production of a good,
what should happen
to my inventory?
This is not a trick question.
AUDIENCE: Goes up.
JAMES PAINE: It's
going to go up.
Woo!
If I increase my
shipments of a good,
what's going to happen
to my inventory?
It's going to go down.
You guys are-- woo!
You guys are great.
So there you go.
So these are causal loops,
or causal links, similarly.
Let's say I have orders booked--
and now, you could
argue that there's
some missing components
in here, but we're
keeping this really high-ended.
If I have more
salesforce in general,
what do you think would
happen to the number of orders
I have booked?
Increase, yep.
If I increase my
price, how many orders
do you think I'm going to get?
They're going to go
down, exactly, yeah.
Pretty straightforward.
One more and then I'll leave
you guys alone with this one.
Population.
More people are born,
it's going to go up.
More people die, it's
going to go down.
Great.
Causal links, straightforward.
Where it gets a little tricky
is when you have an ambiguity.
If all of a sudden
you say to yourself,
well, you know, salesforce,
I don't know about that.
Maybe if I hire too many
people with my salesforce,
then suddenly they start
conflicting with each other.
Maybe they start going
after each other.
Maybe they start overlapping,
and maybe customers
get annoyed because
they get too many calls,
so maybe it will go down.
The moment you have this idea
that that causal sign could
be a plus or minus, that
implies that there's
something in the middle.
That means that that loop does
not exist in and of itself,
there is structure that you have
missing that you need to add.
Now, something also, too,
kind of the same idea--
causal thinking.
And some of you guys might
have seen this already.
Causal thinking is
truly causal thinking.
It needs to be causal,
not purely corollary.
So ice cream-- so
this is generally
true-- as ice cream sales goes
up, so does the murder rate.
So next time they open
up a new Baskin-Robbins,
we should maybe change towns.
I guess that's what that means.
Now, as you guys can probably
guess, what that really means
is that there's
something missing.
This is not truly
causal, instead
we have the average temperature.
As the average
temperature goes up,
people start interacting
with each other more,
they start going outside more.
Just the amount of incidents
of people kind of interacting
goes up, murder rate
happens to go up.
Additionally, people
want more ice cream.
So there.
In that case, we have
something in between.
So something to keep in mind
when you build a causal loop
diagram is that
word causal, when
you're putting this together.
And then, if you
have time, I would
encourage you guys to go
just like, I'm going to try--
I'm going to run these
slides by the faculty
and make sure there's
nothing in here
that I'm not supposed to
share, but assuming I can,
I'm going to send this out to
everybody as well so you'll
have access to these slides.
One of my favorite websites,
Spurious Correlations.
They have all sorts of fun
little things like that.
So, now, bringing it all
together into a loop.
So in this case, we have a
basic loop of employee skill
versus customer
satisfaction, complaints,
manager's time spent
resolving customer issues,
and manager time spent
coaching employees.
I'm going to walk through
this really quickly.
Again, we only have
a few hours to talk.
So normally, this would be a
little-- if you guys end up
taking one of the
system dynamics classes,
we step through
this very carefully.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What do
you mean by causal?
JAMES PAINE: So causal,
in and of itself--
you raise an excellent point.
Causal, in and of itself,
is the degree to which
you have confidence on it.
So at the end of
the day, causality
is the realm of mathematicians
and physicists, in my opinion.
True, true unresolved causality.
So causality in the sense
that, if one thing occurs,
the other thing if, and only--
one thing occurs if, and
only if, the other thing
occurs, that they truly are
connected in time and space.
When one happens, the
other one follows.
Corollary is that that
may still hold true,
but the reason
they're happening is
because of an in-between
mechanism that is driving both.
So where this gets
kind of tricky is,
the lines of causality
become blurred
when you start talking
about macro-social systems.
And ultimately, this is the same
idea that all models are wrong,
but some models are useful.
There's a certain
point of time where
you have to pump
the brakes and say,
all right, this is causal
enough for my purposes
and I'm going to move on.
But the same thing-- when
you said the moment you
have a time where
that loop polarity
can shift or, suddenly,
something increasing causes
another thing to increase.
Now, suddenly, that
same thing increasing
is causing everything
to decrease.
Those are no longer
causally-related in space
and time.
There's something in between.
There's some
mechanism in between
that's causing that thing
to go up in this direction
causes this other thing
to go up and/or down
depending upon some
in-between circumstance.
The moment that
degree of specificity
is necessary, then suddenly
that causal link needs to get
split out into more
detailed structure.
Maybe I'm diving
into too much detail.
Is that helpful?
Kind of?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you mentioned
physics, but like there's
a perspective of physics
in which you actually look
at the physics equations,
there is no real such
thing as causality,
there are just states
of the universe that
are mathematically consistent
and states of the universe that
are not, so causality-- so
it's like, causality really
depends on the assumptions
of your system.
Like, you're
assuming that things
could have been different, but
in reality, they couldn't have.
So I guess I was--
the operational
definition of [INAUDIBLE]..
JAMES PAINE: You're
completely right.
Is your background either
physics or mathematics?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, physics.
JAMES PAINE: Aha, there we go.
So yeah.
No, no, you raise
an excellent point,
because I had the
same conversation
with a couple of other
folks in the physics group.
And within our-- what it boils
down to-- within our social
system modeling, our definition
of causality is loose at best--
but ultimately,
it boils down to,
if one thing moves
in one direction,
another thing moves
in the same direction
consistently every time.
The moment that you can't
say the phrase consistently
every time, then that concept
of causality breaks down.
Just so you...
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when you're
dealing with social systems,
does it become a little
bit less [INAUDIBLE]
and more statistical?
JAMES PAINE: Yeah.
To be very honest
with you, I have
to be careful because I
think some folks in the group
might disagree with me on this.
But again, my background
coming from control theory
and operations management is
that the realm of causality
and the realm of correlation
are degrees of convenience
at the end of the day.
This is a gigantic
asterisk in the top corner.
This is the opinion
of James Paine.
Please do not necessarily tell
other faculty that that's me.
But yes, it is a
division of convenience.
And ultimately, what
it boils down to me,
is that, if you shove
something in one direction,
does another thing
constantly move
the same way every single time?
The moment that it doesn't,
then they're no longer
coupled within these systems.
That's the very, sort of,
hand-wavy, simplistic way
of approaching it.
AUDIENCE: All else being equal.
JAMES PAINE: All
else being equal.
That's a good point.
All else being equal.
So here.
I'm going to go through
these loops real quick.
This is good.
So this, I think, is
pretty straightforward.
This is the whole idea that,
as your employee skill-- this
is, again, very general--
employee skill goes up,
your customer
satisfaction goes up.
Customer satisfaction goes
up, complaints go down.
Times that your
manager now spends
resolving customer
issues goes down,
so now the manager has more
time to coach employees.
So guess what?
Employee skill goes up.
This is an example
of a causal loop.
You start at one variable,
yet work your way
all the way around to
the same variable again.
Now, I'm speeding up
here just a little bit
for the sake of
time, but let's just
go ahead and say that we
somehow exogenously increased
the amount of time
that managers can
spend coaching their employees.
I don't know, we somehow give
them extra time in their day.
What does that mean?
Well, this would imply
that our employee
skill you'd expect to go up.
And if our employee
skill expects to go up,
then we expect our customer
satisfaction to go up.
We'd expect our complaints
to correspondingly go down,
based upon these
causal diagrams.
If our complaints go down,
then the manager time
spent resolving issues goes
back up, which suddenly means
that the amount of time
they have available to them
goes back up again.
We've gone all the
way back up the loop,
we've increased one
variable by a little bit,
and we've gotten a positive
gain around that loop.
If any of you have any
experience with control theory,
this will look familiar.
This is a positive gain
or reinforcing loop.
This is a loop that,
essentially, runs away
in one direction or another.
When one variable starts going
a little bit up or a little
bit down, by its action,
it causes a cascade
of events that causes it
to go more up or more down
within that space.
Correspondingly, we
can have something--
I think you guys
can tell where this
is going-- called the
balancing loop, to get ahead
of myself a little bit.
So in this case, the general
attractiveness of your market
goes up, the number of
competitors within that space--
you could imagine-- would go up.
Your product price-- this is due
to competitive interactions--
might go down.
This is an example of an
aggregated causal diagram.
I think you can make a really
strong argument that those
are not necessarily
perfectly causally-related,
but for our conversation,
it's good enough.
Product price goes down.
Your profits, all
else being equal,
you'd imagine would go down.
That's-- OK.
I think I did that one
a little backwards.
We'll find out.
Anyway, balancing loop.
So the whole idea with
the balancing loop
is that a small--
these are loops where they
tend to balance themselves out.
You have some sort
of external stimuli
that pokes a variable up
or pokes a variable down,
it will act in a way to return
back to its initial position.
A good example of a balancing
loop that comes up a lot
is called the goal-seeking loop.
In this case, you have some
sort of desired performance out
in the universe and
your system will
act to close a gap
relative to that.
I'm showing you guys a
structure kind of relatively
quickly to give you some
chunks of system dynamics
compartmental models that
you might see frequently.
So the right way to tell if you
have a balancing or reinforcing
loop is you trace the
behavior, like we did before.
You pick a variable, you
kick it in a direction--
plus or minus--
and you see what happens when
you loop it all the way around.
There's a quick way to do it,
which is count the negative.
If there is an even
number, then it
is a reinforcing
loop, zero or even.
If it is an odd number,
then it's a balancing loop.
The part where that gets a
little wonky is that if you
mislabeled it in some way,
shape, or form, then suddenly
that no longer makes sense.
So that's my little asterisk
in the top corner there.
Stocks and flows.
So stocks and
flows, ultimately--
I'm going to skip ahead a little
bit here-- are anything that--
a stock is anything that has
memory within this space.
So if you go back to the
origins of system dynamics
and its applications
in control theory,
a stock is anything
whose value depends
upon the instantaneous or
the accumulation of change
of two other variables.
So how we tend to
show this in our space
is as a bucket with some pipes.
So you have an
inflow coming in, you
have some sort of
accumulation in the middle,
and you have some outflow
coming out of the back end
right there.
This right here, now, allows
your system to have memory.
This is what your system has
when you talk about number
of employees, you
talk about number
of units in your
inventory, something else
that has sort of
stickiness in time,
something that instantaneously
doesn't disappear or change
within one unit of delta time
but rather exists and persists.
So we use something called
the hydraulic metaphor.
This picture-- the quality
of it is really low,
and I should remake it.
It's the idea of a bathtub.
So you have your pipe coming in,
you have your pipe coming out.
And ultimately, you can't get
rid of something in the middle
unless you take it
out of the back end
or turn down the amount of
inflow on the front end.
So a good example of
this is greenhouse gases
in the atmosphere.
What do you do about it?
There's really only two
options at the end of the day.
You have to either
increase net removal
or decrease net emissions.
Those are your two choices.
So that's the one
thing we talk about.
A stock is something that
accumulates over time.
So this is a good
example right here.
This is just some
stocks versus flows.
Your balance sheet versus
your cash flow statement.
Wealth versus income and
expenditures per unit time.
CO2 emissions, vehicle
production-- those
are all flows.
Part of this-- you
can tell-- is based
upon how you define
the variables
at the end of the
day, so you have
to be a little bit careful.
But I will give you this.
Here's one that I kind
of consider a little bit
tricky-- interest rate.
What would you consider
to be an interest
rate, a stock or a flow?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES PAINE: I called it
tricky, so you can probably
think, like, oh, take
what you think it is
and then just flip the answer.
That's what I would do.
So it has the word rate
in it, which immediately
makes me think flow, but it's
actually a rate on money--
it is a price.
It is something that
says that, if you give me
x number of dollars,
I will give you
back x number of dollars over
some period of time elapsing.
In that case, it is a price,
it is a sticky quantity,
it is a stock, so the word
rate there is misleading.
I'm going very quick guys
because I want to give you
guys time for the simulation.
So that right there is
really quick system dynamics
in a nutshell, in terms of both
systems thinking and concepts
and also some of the
fundamental tools
that we use within
stock and flow diagrams.
What I wanted to do next was
transition into actually a very
large group project that
will give us some time
to really experience
some of this firsthand,
and then ultimately,
tie it back in.
But before I do that, I want
to give us a few minutes
to talk about this.
Anyone have any questions about
either System Dynamics Group
at MIT-- and we'll
have some more time
at the end of this-- or
system dynamics and systems
thinking as methodology
at this point?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When do
you think-- or when
is a problem too
complicated for you to say
system dynamics is useful?
What are the bounds
on usefulness
of applying this to a problem?
JAMES PAINE: Well,
the weird thing
is, I won't necessarily
say-- complicated
is not the right word.
I would say that
system dynamics is
a poor predictor of the future
when it comes to precision.
So like, there's an example
of system dynamics, I think,
is good at making models that
predict modes of behavior
but not necessarily point
predictions in the future.
So like, a good example
would be an oscillatory mode.
If this is your idea of-- this
is like your mode of behavior
of something over time--
I don't know-- this is like some
price of something over time,
and you make a model
that ultimately shows
that, given some period,
some set of inputs,
I can do something like affect
the amplitude and periodicity
of this scale but ultimately
does show something that kind
of changes with time,
but for some reason
my model is just
a little bit off.
The question is,
which is useful--
knowing that I have this
sort of up-and-down amplitude
and here are the
things or features
that either predict a change in
that amplitude and frequency,
or is it more useful to
know that the price is
going to be this versus this
at this time in the future?
And the issue with any
sort of systems model
is, the moment you move far
enough away from whatever
your current sort
of stab in space
is, you can be just as
wrong as you can possibly
be when it comes to point
predictions in the future.
So my argument is
that system dynamics
is good at coming up with models
where you can start looking
for these modes of
behavior and identifying
the chunks of structure
that have a large policy
impact on affecting or adjusting
these modes of behavior,
not necessarily figuring
out am I going to be
here or here at time this.
So that's-- yeah.
I got to use the
whiteboard, so that's fun.
OK, cool.
So what we're going to do--
this is another bit of bread
and butter of the MIT
System Dynamics Group--
a management flight simulator.
This is the whole idea of
working on mental models.
Ultimately, getting someone's
hands dirty with something
like this and getting
an opportunity
to experience it firsthand
is one of the best ways
to teach concepts from system
dynamics and systems thinking.
So Fishbanks.
Fishbanks was originally
developed quite a number
of years ago as a board game--
and I think you
guys will figure out
very quickly what it's trying
to elicit out of you all.
This is a smart group of folks.
But it has now been
turned into kind
of this interactive simulation.
So for the next hour and some
change as we go through this--
I know everyone here has
different backgrounds,
different businesses, different
things you've been exposed to,
but this is going
to be your business.
Your business is going to be
deep sea and coastal fisher
people.
Your job is to go out there
and catch fish as best you can
and make as much money.
You are all endowed with
your own small fleet
of boats and your own
commercial fishing operation.
Congratulations, welcome aboard.
So that's all I'm going
to say about Fishbanks.
Again, there's a lot more
stuff to say about this,
but I'm going to go
ahead and wrap this up,
because, again, we only
have three hours in total.
Before I do that, any final
questions about the simulation
itself?
Any accusations that I
rigged the whole thing
and made it impossible?
Or anything fun like that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: One of the major,
like, one of the teams
also found out that their
change happened too fast,
and I think that's because
we didn't understand
the system or the equations
behind it, the model.
Was that information
left out intentionally?
JAMES PAINE: To a degree.
So one interesting way to run
this simulation-- and it's been
done, but it hasn't been
done for a long time--
is to essentially run this
whole thing again with you.
Like, essentially let
every person in this room
play the game again,
but understandably,
with slightly
different parameters,
like so you can't just set
it straight to what you
want to do right off the bat.
So the argument here is that
information is imperfect,
but it is still present
and some information
is better than no information.
So the constant
question is, what
happens when you guys know
this information ahead of time?
I'd be curious about that.
For those who did the beer
game, one of the things
that came out of that
that's interesting,
the beer game is this
multi-echelon supply chain.
The ultimate thing about it
is that information matters,
information is helpful.
When you play the beer game with
people who have played the beer
game, you still get the
exact same outcome no matter
how many times you do it.
And one of the
classic examples is
we had a beer game, like,
championship here at MIT
some years ago where not only
was it people who played before
but it was professors who teach
the beer game in the same room.
And we also gave information.
So typically in the beer
game, there's some--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES PAINE: I know, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] But even the folks
who teach the beer game didn't
escape the beer game.
So part of this is
that as long as--
and this is the whole idea
of structure yields behavior.
The structure is still there.
The underlying
structure still exists.
It is real hard to break
your behavior patterns
when you don't change
that underlying structure.
So if you want more, we're
all up on the fourth floor,
for one thing.
So at least, I don't lock
my door, so come on in.
I'll talk your ear off.
For classes here at MIT, a lot
of what we just talked about
is covered really in much more
detail in 15.871, Introduction
to System Dynamics.
I would say 15.871's
primary purpose
is to get these ideas of
systems thinking in your head.
You'll be spending a lot
of time in that class
up on a chalkboard, sort of
talking through problems,
saying, OK, well, let's talk
about what happens when you
increase consumer satisfaction.
What does that mean?
And start drawing these
lovely causal loop diagrams
and think to ourselves,
OK, well, what happens
if we snip this loop here?
And what would it
take to do that?
So it's much more about
how to get yourself
thinking from linear direction
into more of a looping
direction.
15.872 dives a lot more into now
taking those thought processes
and applying them to sort of
much more realistic scenarios
and situations and getting
more comfortable with modeling
tools.
Both involve you
using software sets,
which I'll talk about a little
bit later, that are commonly
used within system dynamics.
But 15.872 kind of takes
the training wheels off.
And there is no--
there is no right
there is no wrong answer as
long as you can figure out
a good self-contained simulation
that gets the conclusion you
think is interesting.
This one is relatively
new, 15.873.
This is somewhere that sits
in between 15.871 and 872.
This is one who's, I like to
think, has more of an emphasis
on business and policy.
I have this example down here.
This is the Vasa, which
I'm now giving away
a slide from, I think, 15.872.
The Vasa was an
incredible ship that
was built by some of the best
ship designers of its day,
was launched, and then promptly
tipped completely upside down
and sunk to the
bottom of the ocean.
And the reason was because,
at the last minute,
there were several
late design adds.
Someone decided they wanted
to build the captain's
lodge a little bit larger.
They wanted to add
a few more sails.
a ton more cannons.
They wanted to make it
more and more impressive.
It became hydro dynamically
unstable, promptly tipped over.
So the idea being here that--
I emphasize that
one for this idea
that you have
unintended consequences.
There are no side effects.
There are simply effects
that you didn't plan for.
And that's kind of
emphasized a little bit more
in 15.872, 15.873.
In terms of books, I
brought a few with me.
Again, I mentioned this at
the beginning of the class.
This has become sort
of the bible of system
dynamics, business dynamics.
The first couple
of chapters cover
a lot of what we talked about.
Later on, it gets
really specific.
There's an opening in here
that says, essentially,
if you have a background
in math, that's great.
If you don't, that's great.
But later on, it starts talking
about the specific differences
between choosing modes
of feedback and behavior,
how to model specific
things, really
how to get your hands dirty for
primarily compartmental models.
If you want something
a little more general,
there is the Fifth
Discipline Field Book.
I wouldn't necessarily
recommend the whole book
unless that's your thing.
But part two is called
systems thinking.
It does a great job of
summarizing the work
that we talked about here.
Both of these books are
in the Dewey Library.
I checked earlier today.
I think this is one of the
two copies of this book.
Sell or return it
right after this class.
But there's lots of copies
of John's book on business
dynamics.
If you want to know
a little bit more
about sort of the history
of this, Limits to Growth
is a book that I recommend
because it has a strong history
in system dynamics.
It also has a bit of a
controversial history,
if you dive into it.
This was one of those
first books that
applied the ideas of overshoot
and collapse to the earth,
and saying that we as a species
are headed towards this,
and we need to
manage our resources
and we need to be a little bit
more careful with our choices.
The simulations in there
had some specific dates
that ultimately
were held up as sort
of the how why
point prediction is
difficult in system dynamics.
So if you read it, this is not
a prediction for the future.
It's discussing the
mode of behavior.
It's talking about the
structure that we currently
have that can lead to
overshoot and collapse
within shared resources.
Articles, if you get a chance,
it's my personal favorites.
System Dynamics at Sixty:
The Path Forward, I think,
does a great job of
kind of saying where
is system dynamics right now.
A lot of material
that you get out there
talks about where
system dynamics
was 20, 30, even 40 years ago.
I think this one does a great
job of saying, that's great.
What are we doing from now?
This is essentially
the article that says,
system dynamics is not
compartmental models.
System dynamics is
a mode of thinking.
Choose the software
that you need to.
Choose the methods of
communication you need to.
I am, again, someone who does
a lot of operations management.
So most of these
choices up there
about compatibility traps and
sort of operational failure,
that's kind of where
I'm coming from.
But that being said,
this one right here,
the third one on the
list, Making the Numbers,
applies a classic operations
management concept
of a capability trap
to valuation of stocks.
And I think that's a great
little connection right there.
If you happen to be
on MIT'S network,
these are all free
and accessible.
The worst case scenario,
I'll print out a copy for you
because I think these
are good articles.
Other websites.
Some personal favorites here.
Creative Learning
Exchange, this is
one-- it's primarily K
through 12 education-focused.
But there's a lot of fun
little tools on there.
It uses a lot of animations,
make things very approachable,
especially if you're
used to looking
at sort of cold, black
and white diagrams.
Clicking around on there
just kind of makes me happy,
like it has lots of pink
fluid flowing back and forth,
and you like-- you attach
the little things together.
They have some fun iOS
and Android applications.
Tom Fiddaman's MetaSD
website is fantastic.
He has-- that man will
just model anything
that he thinks is interesting.
So if you have a blank piece
of software in front of you
and you don't know what to
click and you want something
as an example, he
has one about sort
of the self-reinforcing
nature of UFO sightings.
So he essentially
thinks to himself,
this is an interesting
behavior I have observed.
I wonder what structure
could have yielded it?
And then he makes it and
puts it on his website.
So that's just a fun
one to click around on.
This one, the
self-study website,
that is dense, to be honest.
But it's a good spot to start.
This systematically walks
you through the fundamentals
of system dynamics from open
concept to detailed modeling
systematically.
And is free and open
for anyone to use.
I run, right now,
the Journal Club.
So that's my plug right there.
Stop on by.
Every other Friday, once
the semester starts,
or every Friday once
we have a seminar series
that's systematic-focused up
on the fourth floor.
If there's not a
seminar scheduled,
then I just kind of run
the discussion and talk
about something I feel
like talking about.
And then of course, the
System Dynamics Society.
That's kind of
our group society.
I would be remiss if I did
not at least mention them
in passing.
It's a lot of information,
but I think especially
those first two are
not ones that you
see a lot are recommended.
Software.
We didn't talk at
all about software.
If this had been a longer
course, that probably would
be the next thing I'd do is
I'd dive into some software
with you guys.
Unfortunately, we
don't have the time.
So I want to point
you in these--
towards these guys right here,
Vensim and Stella Architect.
Vensim especially has a
free academic license.
If you also have an
MIT email address,
you can get more or less
the full commercial version
for free, which is nice.
The difference between
the personal learning
edition and the
commercial edition
is minimal until you hit it.
And then once you
hit it, you really
want that commercial
version for being
able to just do some stuff.
So if you have an
MIT email address,
I suggest spending
the three minutes
to get a Vensim
professional license.
Stella Architect is less used in
our group, but definitely used
in general.
They have a great
storytelling mode,
this idea of building up
your models progressively
without scaring
people away, kind of.
And also have a lot
of nice visuals.
I'm still getting used
to that software myself,
but I like what I see.
Also, off to the
side there, NetLogo.
Not used a lot in our
group necessarily,
but I use it a lot.
It's a good old
agent-based model.
So sometimes it's
useful to think, OK,
I know what a person
would do or an agent
or an entity in the setup.
I can wrap my head around that.
I don't know what
the system is, but I
can wrap my head around one
person wandering through space.
This lets you, essentially,
model that person
and then put a whole
bunch of them in a room
and see what happens.
If anyone has done any sort
of agent-based modeling
with any sort of scripting
language, MATLAB, R, anything
else like that, this is
kind of the same concept
with a nice little
pretty wrapper
around the outside of it.
Speaking of which,
in terms of software,
we use all sorts of software.
It's not just Vensim and Stella.
These are just what I have
upstairs on my machine
right now.
Actually, they're on
my machine right now
and what I use on more
or less a daily basis.
We're not just
compartmentalize models.
We're a mode of thinking.
So if you have a tool
that gets the job done,
than good for you.
It's possible to do a good
causal diagram using Excel
if you're really motivated.
Oh yeah, and a whiteboard.
Whiteboard definitely
gets the job done.
That's actually-- he
raises a great point.
The best use is just standing
in front of our whiteboard
and starting writing
some things down.
People often ask the
question, what do you do?
Like, how do you start?
Like, what's the
first thing you do?
I'd say walk up to
a whiteboard, think
about the thing you care about.
I don't know, it's
CO2 in the atmosphere,
car deaths, number of people
quitting from a non-profit.
Write that on a board.
Just write it smack dab in
the middle of the board.
Then think to yourself,
what would cause that thing
to go up or down?
Write it off to the side.
Draw an arrow, put a plus
or a minus next to it.
And just keep going
and see what happens.
And let those loops
come back around.
And that's a good spot to start.
So that's-- we
have a few minutes.
I'm going to click this
one thing right here
for another example of
system dynamics in action.
If anyone is familiar with
the policy interactive,
this is an idea too of what's
the most complicated model sort
of idea and what can you do.
This is En-ROADS.
This is a policy
simulator for the climate.
So this right here has a
full-blown climate simulation
running on the back.
But its job at
the end of the day
is again, not point prediction.
Its job is policy.
So again, this is one
kind of a fun thing
to click around and kind of
see system dynamics in action.
This is simply saying, what
are we doing right here?
What's our predicted
temperature change over time?
What are the choices that we can
make as a society, as a group,
as a series of countries
to change this outcome?
This is being used right now
in conversations with members
of our own government in order
to help elicit mental models
and get people on the
same page about climate
action in the future.
And so this is
something else where
there is a big
compartmental model running
in the background.
But this is an example
of using system dynamics
to hopefully elicit real
policy change in the near term.
So you can start clicking
around, seeing what happens.
I'll be honest, I'm
really bad at this one.
I click around and I realize
I'm really bad at figuring out
how to fix the climate,
which is why I do operations
and supply chain management, I
suppose, at the end of the day.
So yeah, I'd encourage you
guys to click around on that.
So that, essentially,
is where we are.
Thank you guys very much.
I loved sharing system
dynamics with you,
and I hope to see some of
you guys in the future.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]